haha the Joe Rogan experience the 80s
was a special time and there's so many
things there's so many things 80s Miami
Vice yes right there's so many things
80s that were just 80s yeah yeah Miami
Vice man who didn't he would he have a
Lamborghini or something like that or
sorry testa Rossa yeah testa Rossa that
way yeah the white testa Rossa with the
things on the side Crockett and Tubbs
yeah pastel suits yes with no socks they
had no socks on always look at him
loafers no socks not a bad show back
that was a Ferrari that car yeah that
was a different Ferrari
I think that was what he had early he
had that one that and then he got the
Testarossa
that's weird being the other guy though
right like Don Johnson entire career
gotta suck and then you're the what will
we watch and there was some Oh
transformers was on right and you know
in the first scene in the Transformers
when they're in the desert and it's like
there's like five military guys you know
and then the first three to get killed I
was like imagine being one of those guys
and then you watch Tyrese Gibson and the
other guy go on to this billion-dollar
franchise and like you got killed in the
first scene like ulam why didn't I live
by the way I've been that guy in a few
movies I haven't done I haven't done
many I've done maybe five I am very
strict in my casting I can be a security
guard or a bouncer played a security
guard as a bouncer and when you think
about those kind of shows like fast and
furious like those movies how the [ __ ]
did that happen how do those movies make
that much money it's a simple formula
but how many people are buying that
simple formula over and over again how
is it happening because it's it's almost
like a cartoon right listen I live the
first Fast and Furious came out it's
like okay we got cars we got women we
got guns do we even need a script
do we even need a script just turn it
loose and that's what every movie right
that's yeah like yeah just bake the cars
bigger make the guns bigger make the
guys big drifting right women are hotter
yeah if you watch The Fast and Furious
Tokyo Drift
apparently every schoolgirl in Japan is
wearing a Catholic school miniskirt at
all times but it works it's a simple
formula
absolutely I got 1 billion 518 million
seven hundred twenty two thousand seven
hundred ninety four oh my god that's the
one movie but that's the Furious 7 one
movie made that much money but look at I
mean do their movies made over a billion
dollars yeah why wouldn't they don't
need to it's a cartoon formula that
works that's amazing it's a formula that
works it's a six billion worldwide
flashy beaut get stuff like that you
know yeah how could it not work how
could it not work and if I tell you I'm
the head writer if I tell you I wrote
The Fast and Furious I how you gonna
prove me wrong but that was part of the
first the first movies were muscle
versus yeah Tudor right they even got
you they got you in the beginning you
got the muscle car no what I'm saying is
but the muscle car guy yeah they got the
muscle cars but they didn't get movie no
not you but you know what I'm saying but
they got the muscle car fans in the
beginning and anymore Vin Diesel drove
the muscle car all the time right he had
that dodge of Chrysler whatever it was
yeah he he had that through like the
first three movies right you know so
much about these men oh I love watching
those man Joe I love bad movies man do
you
biker boys biker thank you biker boys
has to be wanted to I just turned
someone onto it
laughs its laurence fishburne in a
motorcycle drag racing movie and it's
not just him orlando e3 2003 Orlando
Jones is in that's Orlando Jones right
there look at Laurence are you kidding
Kid Rock Kid Rock is in the Kid Rock
rise the white biker gang it's a world
fueled by God I might just found my new
favorite movie holy [ __ ] this looks bad
that's oh there's Kid Rock would a dog
it's a life driven by respect oh my god
wait a minute that's a black dude with a
motorcycle vest why they have the same
kind of motorcycle veces like Hells
Angels which is so silly
yeah Larenz Tate right yeah man I love I
love bad car and bike movies this day I
love those and the other bad movies are
like the badass chick like she kicks
everyone's ass but it's like a bad movie
but she's badass going through it
whenever you know whenever they're like
they hit me what you may also like also
like I want to see it I want to see it
yes you may also like you're damn right
I'm good oh my god look yeah biker boys
and torque fight towards another one
twerking biker boys were the same movie
they tried to do a fast and furious on
motorcycles now torque Stars Ice Cube
and it's like loads a white biker group
in a black biker group and ice cubes in
it and and Dane isn't it Dane Cook's in
it and just yeah
they were horrible movement they were in
comic and as a motorcycle rider they're
even better because it's even worse man
it was so much fun
drag race in there there you go wow that
looks yeah that's torque from the movie
yeah oh look that's him that bike is
that was actually made Leno has one of
those it's a jet-powered motorcycle
that's a joke he doesn't fly like that
but what the hell why it's that dude who
is in 30 days and of nights maybe I
don't know yeah he's a bad guy in a lot
of movies he's just really good as a bad
guy
yeah come on man how do you not watch
this looking at each other in downtown
LA Alonso you get to see the bullet
[Applause]